die nordrhein westfälische stadt kleve
hat vor anderthalb jahren diesen
schicken neuen bahnsteig gebaut samt
neuen busbahnhof kosten insgesamt rund
2,4 millionen euro
doch die schöne neue bahnhaltestelle hat
ein ganz gewaltiges problem der zug
kommt gar nicht bis dahin sehr auch
nicht der schon wieder nicht und der
schon gar nicht die pendler können es
nicht glauben ein bahnhalt ohne züge
fassungslos kann fast sagen weil es
einfach totaler unsinn einfach
bürokratie wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
merkwürdig warum das nicht möglich ist
vor allen dingen weil das hier alles
gebaut wurde und alle menschen auch hier
sitzen könnten mir ist der zugriff vor
der nase weggefahren
ich saß hier am bahnsteig wo eigentlich
wo ich dachte dass der zug der held und
100 meter weiter stand der zug und ist
irgendwann weg gefahren immer 2016 wurde
der schicke kombi bahnsteig eingeweiht
doch die züge halten noch immer am alten
maroden bahnhofsgebäude das dach ist
notdürftig abgestützt
die regenrinne gleicht einem sieg für
die fahrgäste eine zumutung der grund
für die absurde situation ist dieses
kleine schild züge bis zu einer länge
von 100 metern müssen vor diese halte
tafel stoppen seit eineinhalb jahren hat
es niemand geschafft das schild ans ende
des bahnsteigs zu setzen damit die züge
endlich vor dem neuen dach halten dürfen
aber warum hat die stadt kleve als
bauherr nicht für einen vernünftigen
übergang zum busbahnhof gesorgt im
rathaus weist man jede verantwortung
weit von sich das ist bahn sache also
ich glaube nicht dass eine
stadtverwaltung sich um haltesignale in
den gleisen kümmern muss also und
außerdem waren mehrfach angeschrieben
immer wieder gab es auch von
bahnreisenden beschwerden passiert ist
nichts
doch kurz nach unseren dreharbeiten dann
plötzlich das voraussichtlich in dieser
woche greifen betriebliche maßnahmen für
einen halteplatz der die neuen baulichen
gegebenheiten berücksichtigt
aha nachdem anderthalb jahre nichts
passiert ist
soll jetzt auf einmal alles ganz schnell
gehen die leute sind bedient und wenn
man so was plant sollte man so was schon
vernünftig planen ziemlich lächerlich
das ist um so ein kleines schild geht
die bahn hat uns telefonisch mitgeteilt
dass der zug ab diesem wochenende
endlich da halten soll wo er hingehört
und das alberne haltesignal desaster
damit endlich ein ende hätte